Elon did not release the Twitter files  to CNN or to the New York Times or to  Washington Post or even the Wall Street  Journal  it doesn't matter who he gives it to  they're going to try to take him out  because he didn't give it to them  your CNN's Christine Romans saying that  now this stuff that's not a big deal  you would you could you do you win  winner said which is a immediate  Watchdog group they said um file this  one under file the Twitter files under M  for Math and the Washington Post said  There Are No No Smoking Gun here  see here please we have to accept that a  certain amount of people just by the  state line they just are non-playable  characters if they hear something that's  how it is mainstream set it so that's  how it is that's why I keep saying the  truth is a Time release pill these days